president biden threatening consequences
before his big phone call with china's
president today warning the communist
country against helping out russia's
invasion but now that the call is over
the white house says president biden
did not
make any specific requests of china but
instead laid out his assessment of the
situation great president biden wasn't
making specific requests of china why
not and given the stakes here because
china has to make a decision for
themselves about where they want to
stand
and how they want the history books to
look at them and view their actions and
that is a decision for president xi and
the chinese to make can you offer any
explanation for why the u.s still has
concerns after this call because we'll
continue to watch until
we see what actions they take or don't
take jesse in scientific terms that is
called a garbage answer
i mean are they not taking this
seriously there's a two-hour phone call
and they didn't talk about
how to influence putin but just make an
assessment what the hell is going on i
mean what that what a waste of time i
can't believe she said the chinese have
to decide yes how they want the history
books
china writes their own history books
it's not like a world history
come on jen like that seems to be like
the pressure point that's what they say
about putin that's what they say about
cuba the history books the history books
what about right now yeah i don't know
how well joe did on that call but i
don't think he did very well
they give him notes and he looks and he
he's not a commanding presence so that
made me nervous
he has a pretty easy task china screwed
up they hitched their wagon to a loser
there's no way russia wins this thing
and chyna looks really bad now and
she is screwed he put his prestige on
the line for putin he's supposed to be
this big statesman right this big you
know rising power and now everyone's
disgusted with his boy they're disgusted
with him and he's going to try to like
slowly back out of the jam that he's in
and and he gets on the horn with biden
biden probably let him off the hook he
should have been much tougher i'm sure
he wasn't tough i wasn't there but i'm
surmising he he wasn't tough enough you
got to separate these two weasels the
russians from the chinese and you do
that with tough talk and threats
and you do it with you know economic
threats and i don't think biden played
that card no um uh degen
we worry that you know russia is going
to be tethered to china but
doesn't china need america and europe
more than it needs russia i mean we we
buy so much from them russia doesn't buy
much of anything uh china knows that
we're suckers and we're soft
not all americans but that we are
dependent on their cheap imported goods
and the wall street journal phrased it
as because this is not just china and
russia this is china and russia and
india and even saudi arabia that is
trying to move away
from a western dominated world in in
terms of power in terms of
uh economic heft i called it the on your
show on monday the rapid fire
realignment of world power
it is the journal described at the
editorial page as a
union of uh nations that are hostile to
democracy economic freedom and u.s
leadership and even china is lining up
with saudi arabia saudi arabia won't
take joe biden's calls but uh saudi
arabia might agree to china paying for
its oil in in root in
the yuan
china gets
natural resources from russia period and
it will be a huge engine for china's
growth and i in terms of our softness
we've run up our debt so much 130
percent of uh debt to gdp we don't have
the money to take on china at this point
we're so soft that uh the democrats in
california are sending 400 checks to
people to offset the high gas prices and
people who don't even have cars or drive
get them
we're not able to stand and cut off
supplies from china were
i would have done something i'm sorry i
would have said listen chi or however
you say his name i would have said
you're not getting any more visas no
more chinese are going to come to this
country and steal our secrets and rip
off our intellectual property
and if you just supply arms to the
kremlin that's what happens because
that's their whole economy that's the
only way they survive what do you think
jessica
i think jesse stole time from me and the
judge and uh you'll get it back in the
second half
oh i will get it
you'll get to talk all during buying all
right this is more of the stealing okay
so from the readout that we got it does
say that president biden described the
implications and consequences of china
provides material support to russia it
also said that president xi says that a
war in ukraine is in no one's interest
he supports peace
that this has developed to quote such a
point that china doesn't want to see it
now he's still more russia's friend than
our friend but
that's pretty clear he doesn't like it
he doesn't want it but he says it's on
the u.s and nato to broker this deal wow
so
that but that makes sense it's not i
should have read we put that on us
how dare he he put it on us you can see
this he said that
he said that because fundamentally for
putin this is about ukraine wanting to
be part of our system and not part of
putin's system so that seems like a
pretty good call i know you would have
done better but it seems good to me
judge can we can we play alternate
alternate history if
trump was president
first of all
let me say this if trump were president
we wouldn't have had that meeting where
everybody just repeated their own
talking points this was nothing more
than a face-to-face photo op that's all
it was biden got nothing out of it he
didn't get cheetah say gee you're right
joe i'm with you i'm with you on all
this all they said all china said was
look you know um we just we don't like
confrontation we don't believe in war
but do they condem ukraine do they
condemn russia for attacking ukraine
absolutely not and then then they say
china tells us they make it very clear
they say
uh china wants the u.s to promise and
this is in the readout too that there
will be no conflict if they take taiwan
which is their strategic objective and
that's a problem for us because 85
percent of our chips are made in taiwan
and we rely on them so you know the
chinese are blaming us for russia
invading ukraine beca and now it's
jessica's right that it's united states
and nato that have to go
to uh uh putin and tell him to stop and
by the way
um
consequences according to joe biden
to china
is if they provide material support to
russia what is material is it economic
is it financial and by the way joe if
you want to disconnect the united states
from china why don't you stop american
companies that are going over there and
manufacturing all kinds of american
goods in china why don't you make it a
negative for them to do that why are
medicines being made in china why don't
you come up with something if you back
america so that we can manufacture in
the united
states all right up next doctor doom and
gloom is back faucey with a new warning
on coveted lockdowns